qu'est ce que c'est exactement pulsions
oui voilà servis juhasz a permis d'aller
au delà des tricheurs
voilà la définition du surréalisme
paroisse de miro en 1970 ce mouvement
artistique est née au début du 20e
siècle
mais pour certains même des années plus
tard ils restent floues qu'est ce que je
pense du surréalisme ces commissions d
un ami qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de nous
voilà c'est tout ok pourtant ce
mouvement artistique a sa propre
définition
l'écrivain andré breton l'a écrit dans
un manifeste en 1924 quelques lignes
explicative lu en public par le
réalisateur jean christophe averty en
1977 surréalisme pour tous les crétins
compo de fuite veut dire je le répète
donc automatismes psychique pur par
lequel on s'ouvre pour s'exprimer soit
verbalement soit pareil crise que de
toute autre manière le fonctionnement
réel de la pensée
alors c'est plus que l'erreur c'est au
delà du réel
je réalise en je ne sais pas je ne vois
pas qui peut assez intelligent pour
traiter en 2002 des enfants était
interrogé lors d'une exposition sur la
révolution surréaliste devant un tableau
de miro tout était limpide pour ces
petits artistes français avec une tête
mais je trouve que c'est beaucoup mieux
penser de ce que c'est et si finalement
le surréalisme c'était de voir avec nos
yeux d'enfant ça donne de beaux livres
ça donne deux expositions de peinture ça
donne des phrases drôles
- ah ok
[Musique]